je suis le président Barack Obama sur la
ligne de il veut vous féliciter
[Musique]
de la Commission européenne secrétaire
général de l'ONU les leaders syndicaux
évidemment faut les appeler aussi pour
pouvoir leur expliquer tout le monde
même niska
le rappeur
[Musique]
ok allô maman qu'est-ce qui se passe il
y a un problème je suis au travail là
[Musique]
j'ai pas le temps j'ai vraiment pas le
temps allô niska
[Musique]
oh je suis dégoûté je suis dégoûté parce
que les gens ils pensent que c'est qu'un
ambianceur mais je te promets il a une
plume le monde est méchant
c'est comme pour les meufs si tu
rappelles c'est toi qui passe pour un
faible
il a raison il a raison
je sais pas on n'est pas faible nous est
la rue bon j'ai entendu parler de code
nucléaire tout ça c'est où ils sont là
[Musique]